so let's just start from the top how did
you get involved in this project for uh
gremlin's secret of Mogwai well I'm very
happy to be so-called involved in this
series because um you know I've heard of
the Gremlins and uh for a long long time
how many years has it been since the
previous one
about five years or more
since the original it's been like 40 so
yeah so it's been a long time so
obviously I've looked forward to being
in a major hit and a something that has
gone into the families of all of America
and the foreign countries so to be part
of the new one is really an honor yeah I
mean you have a prolific history as a
voice actor
um I have to ask when do you go to sleep
I feel like you're always oh gosh you
know I don't and unfortunately now
because uh after the awards and the star
on the sidewalk of Fame it's been a
constant of interview with uh all the
stations and newspapers uh you know and
and I guess that being the senior member
of the uh Asian acting Community they
want to hear what I or will have to say
about this industry the 70 years that I
have been in Hollywood yeah I mean I
attended the CCA event that you spoke at
uh last year honoring Asian Pacific
Islanders uh and your speech was like so
moving I love to hear I cried when you
were talking about it
um I want to you I want to know did you
ever expect that you would end up at
this spot when you were just starting
out in the industry when I started
I was still a civil engineer
in other words I was studying and uh
Minnesota U of M and then transferred my
credits to USC uh because I thought um
there were opportunities here in
Hollywood and almost none for me in
Minnesota so I transfer all my credits
from U of M to USC and graduated as a
civil engineer you know and worked for
the LA county building roads so it was
then that I was uh even when I was going
to uh USC on the last year I I was
spending my time earning money as being
an extra you know so I was exposed to
that industry and pretty soon my agent
uh said no you you've got to be an actor
so right away she got me jobs and lucky
enough um in a sense I was prepared I I
was averaging 10 movies and TV a year so
I was what they were looking for here in
Hollywood you know
and um I I started the first acting
class uh for the Asian Americans here in
Hollywood and
um so it's been a great adventure
traveling from that instant to what it
is now where we're getting Awards um the
winning Best Director best uh movie and
this everything everywhere all at once
it's a shocking shockingly amazing
because I thought well this is just
another movie you know but little I I
was I a word that the audience was
waiting to see a film as such you know
it still amazes me I can't believe that
we've won the Best Picture award in the
uh the Oscars and when I got hold of
that Oscar I was supposed to pass it
around but I slam onto it and and they
wheel me out to the uh Governor's Ball
and I still hung out to it they try to
come come to the ball and said um uh
James you you they want to get that
Oscar back I said well let them come and
get it you know and so I went on eating
because I hadn't eaten for about seven
hours so soon another bigger guy come
says we really have to have that Oscar
because we're gonna engrave the name on
it not my name of course
oh wait so I said okay take it so I had
to give that Oscar up
one day maybe about to hold it I feel
like you deserve to hold it just as much
as everybody else I mean I have to
congratulate you on everything
everywhere uh that was my favorite movie
of last year I grew up in a
chinese-american family and like my
parents speak Mandarin and Cantonese
watching that on screen was very it just
felt very surreal interesting do you
speak Cantonese
Cantonese I suppose huh
my my dad speaks Cantonese he's also
he's from Shanghai so he also speaks
Shanghai news which I also understand
um so it's a lot it's a lot to take in
but I have to ask you know I I just
watch american-born Chinese too and of
course secrets of the Mogwai you have so
many elements of Chinese mythology being
included what has it been like seeing
that being presented to you know the
mainstream like English language
storytelling and seeing that you know
people watching it and liking it
American Born Chinese I haven't even
seen that yet you know I was there
acting in it one day so I'm very anxious
to see what the whole thing looks like
um it was a very different set I mean
there was a stage and I climbed on the
stage and and uh it just sort of did
things uh out of a dream it wasn't
really a reality reality set nor was the
story at that point uh reality so I'm
looking to see how all that fits in the
same thing I'm looking now at the
scripts and other people doing things
and uh Asian American vehicles are
totally different and I'm so glad the
creators director producers are looking
to you know different aspects of
American Chinese life you know and
pretty soon it'll be commonplace right
now it's still just at the starting
stage yes I agree and we can only go
further so that's right I really want to
thank you for speaking with me
um I just it's such an honor to talk
with you and I can't wait for everybody
to watch this well keep up the good work
you know and Forge forward don't give up
just punch in there okay keep it up
thank you